después de la tormenta de nieve del
martes la nieve en chile town tenía 55
centímetros de profundidad
la nieve siguió cayendo el viernes y se
incrementó unos centímetros
ahora la nieve en chile town tiene 84
centímetros de profundidad y queremos
saber cuántos centímetros de nieve
cayeron el viernes entonces pues lo que
podemos hacer es ver este diagrama de
aquí que ya tiene un montón de la
información que nos dan en este problema
después de la tormenta de nieve del
martes la nieve en chile town tenía 55
centímetros por aquí está la nieve y
aquí nos ponen una regla indicando la
cantidad de centímetros de profundidad
de la nieve de hecho aquí hasta nos
ponen 55 centímetros que es la
profundidad que tenía la nieve después
de la tormenta del martes entonces este
nivel de aquí
es el de 55 centímetros de profundidad
que es el nivel al que llegó la nieve
después de la tormenta del martes
esta profundidad de aquí es de 55
centímetros pero la nieve no paró el
viernes siguió cayendo más nieve y ahora
en chile- town la nieve tiene una
profundidad de 84 centímetros que hay 84
centímetros este es el nivel de nieve de
84 centímetros y queremos saber cuántos
centímetros de nieve cayeron el viernes
aunque lo que quieren que averigüemos es
cuál es esta altura de aquí de hecho
hasta nos ponen un signo de
interrogación lo que hay aquí tenemos
signo de interrogación centímetros
porque está nieve es la que cayó el
viernes entonces cómo le vamos a hacer
para averiguar esto de aquí
pues una buena idea es escribir todo lo
que sabemos que es cierto o bueno no
todo pero algunas cosas que pueden
llegar a ser útiles por ejemplo podemos
escribir que 55 los 55 centímetros de
profundidad de nieve que teníamos
después de la tormenta del martes más
esto que tenemos aquí que como no
sabemos que es vamos a poner simplemente
un signo de interrogación pero estos 55
centímetros más estos otros centímetros
que no sabemos cuántos son esta suma es
igual al total de centímetros que
podemos observar ahorita que son 84
centímetros aunque lo tenemos también
aquí en la regla son 84 centímetros de
nieve y lo que queremos hacer es
averiguar cuánto vale este signo de
interrogación y bueno una forma de
interrogación
es decir ok si 55
el signo de interrogación es igual a 84
entonces 84 84 menos 55 menos 55 es
igual al signo de interrogación ok y
otra forma de pensar por qué sucede esto
es verlo por aquí en el diagrama nuclear
y tenemos 84 y si le quitamos 55 lo que
nos va a quedar es esto de aquí que es
el número que estamos buscando caisse
estos 84 centímetros de nieve le
quitamos 55 centímetros de nieve nos va
a quedar esta cantidad de aquí que es
justo la nieve que cayó el viernes por
acá entonces 84 menos 55 84 55 es la
cantidad de nieve que cayó el viernes
entonces queremos hacer esta resta
voy a borrar esto de aquí tenemos 84 84
y le queremos restar 55 55 resta y esta
resta va a ser igual a nuestro signo de
interrogación
así es que vamos a empezar por las
unidades tenemos 4 menos 5 pero como 4
es más chico que 5 entonces vamos a
tener que reagrupar estas decenas de
estas ocho decenas vamos a pedir
prestada una decena y entonces nos
quedan siete decenas y la otra decena la
vamos a convertir en diez unidades
entonces tenemos esas diez unidades que
pedimos prestadas más estas cuatro
unidades o sea que tenemos catorce
unidades y ahora sí ya podemos hacer la
resta nunca tenemos catorce unidades
menos cinco unidades
esas son nueve unidades y luego tenemos
siete decenas menos cinco decenas lo que
nos queda son dos decenas
entonces el resultado son 29 centímetros
de nieve cayeron 29 centímetros de nieve
el viernes esta altura de aquí es de 29
centímetros y de hecho lo puedes checar
por aquí porque hay 55 más 29 si es
igual a 84 te recomiendo que cheques que
realmente 55 29 es igual a 84 entonces
cuántos centímetros de nieve cayeron el
viernes cayeron 29 centímetros pero
bueno lo importante para problemas como
éste es recordar la historia que está
detrás y entender muy bien qué es lo que
está pasando en esa historia y a partir
de la información que sabes la
información que te están dando en el
problema y que puedes ver aquí en tu
diagrama escribir cosas matemáticas
aunque hay algunas personas dirían que
son como afirmaciones matemáticas
aunque hay ecuaciones entonces con la
información y los diagramas escribes
ecuaciones que sabes que son ciertas y a
partir de eso encuentras lo que estás
buscando